people need to hear it because you know
you'll think i'm making this stuff up
let's play it
so we really want to
to to base our treatment and uh and to
affirm and to uh support and empower
these youth not to limit their
participation in activities in sports
and even uh limit their ability to get
gender affirmation treatment in their
state okay so gender africa
that's what that is that winds up being
hormone therapy it winds up being things
like puberty blockers and in some cases
it winds up being surgery for children
that's what's being advocated so i i
write something above it and i said run
on this democrats i dare you
and it went people liked it there were a
lot of people that shared that
listen
i invite you democrats i am this is an
open invitation really if you believe in
this stuff
and you claim that you do you know you
have someone a very high ranking
official out there saying as such if you
believe this then stand by it
make this part of the platform this time
around i want to see what happens